the cultural revolution now in progress
is making a dangerous term it's actually
been here for quite some time you're
watching elected leaders say you were
not allowed to participate in our system
if you're the wrong color
during a recent argument on the House
floor Democratic congressman Cedric
Richmond of Louisiana argued that some
people just shouldn't be in the debate
because they're the wrong skin color or
their children are Richmond's claims
start off with a fight with Florida
congressman Matt gates you all are white
males you never lived in my shoes and
you do not know what it's like to be an
african-american male are you suggesting
that you're certain that none of us have
non-white children because you reflected
on your black son and you said none of
us could understand men stop I'm not
about to get sidetracked about the color
of our children we're talking about
black I reclaim my time it is not about
the color of your kids
it is about black males black people in
the streets that are getting killed in a
move one of them happens to be your kid
I'm concerned about him too
and clearly I'm more concerned about him
than you are so let's be clear about
that claiming so you're claiming right
for my family that I do who in the hell
you generally walk gentlemen if the shoe
fits you don't know how dog Hodges you
should take those words down my
gentleman does her family above your
family the gentleman will suspend
the gentleman's to spend the time
belongs to the gentleman from Louisiana
was that a nerve yeah gentleman from
Louisiana when you attack people on the
basis of their race and their children
you get exchanges like that it's
disgusting
of course Cedric Richmond will never be
disciplined for it afterward Matt Gaetz
issued this statement on Twitter for all
those wondering this is my son Nestor we
share no blood but he is my life he came
from Cuba legally of course six years
ago and lives with me in Florida
congressman Matt Gaetz joins us
congressman thanks so much for coming on
so what Cedric Richmond who by the way
what's a Tulane law school and brags
about his Harvard degree mr. a pressed
character here was telling you that
you're not allowed to participate in the
car
because of your skin color I believe
everyone should be able to participate
if they're black white or otherwise and
it's certainly offensive to have someone
tell you that you know you don't know
what a certain experience is like when
they know nothing about you Nestor is
the light of my life
I couldn't imagine him loving loving him
anymore
if he was my own flesh and blood I've
raised him for the last six years and he
is just the most remarkable young man I
am proud of him
and I am I'm honestly embarrassed for
the United States Congress that we've
resorted to criticizing each other based
on our race and the race of our children
and I wish that we would be more
productive going forward so did any
Republicans your side of the aisle stand
up and make that point I mean it seems
like a pretty basic threshold that we're
not going to attack people for things
they can't control like their skin color
did anyone else join in your defense
well there were some Republicans who you
know pointed out that we shouldn't be
treating anybody differently as a
consequence of their race I've just got
to say though he's a remarkable young
man I am proud of him and I've raised
nest door to believe that in our family
we treat everyone equally it doesn't
matter what their background is what
their race is we treat every American
with respect did you learn that at
school as well do you think I mean do
you think the culture in which he's
growing up reinforces that obvious and
most American of all messages well why
don't you ask him Tucker he's he's I
think piped in from the studio in
Florida
Nestor thanks for joining us what do you
make of Cedric
Richmond's attacks it he's you see all
this I did not see it because I was
sleeping from my workout from the night
before but yes once I woke up I I woke
up to see in all these tweets and I was
like what's going on and might get me a
call telling me about it and then I saw
it and I think it's kind of unfair to uh
you know not a tune up to tell someone
that they don't understand because they
don't have like because of their racial
color
well like he's fighting for equal
but if you tell someone tonight not get
involved he doesn't understand because
of his color you kind of been a
hypocrite there yes I think that's very
nicely put Matt I mean congressman Gates
say so just like this out loud seems
like the kind of thing that you know in
normal times you'd be censured for I
cannot believe that it's acceptable in
the United States Congress for someone
to tell someone else that they're
fighting for their children more than
they are Tucker you have a son how would
you feel if someone said to you that
they you know we're fighting for your
own family more than you were so that's
why I got very upset but you know for
the for the sake of Nestor and my story
we're a proud happy family we love each
other very much and Nestor is on his way
off to college in the fall and I just
couldn't be happier and prouder of the
young man he's become and the fact that
he is embracing these American values
that everyone should be treated fairly
and equally that's exactly right
I tell my kids you're not responsible
for who your relatives are in their case
thank heaven you're responsible for what
you do and the choices that you make
that's the promise of America if we
abandon that we're done congressman
thanks so much for coming on Nestor nice
to meet you